[Música]
no me invitaron a dar esta charla pensé
mucho en qué decirles porque se me hace
raro hablar de esta experiencia como un
caso de éxito sin duda acreditar el
examen para notario fue un gran reto
para el que se necesitó mucha disciplina
perseverancia y sobre todo preparación
pero el reto de mi vida ha sido poder
construir la vida de mis sueños a pesar
de las circunstancias
voy a hacer esta charla a partir de la
microhistoria esta es una frase de
gandhi
que me gusta y que se las quería
compartir
la microhistoria es la rama de la
historia social que estudia los eventos
a partir de las personas o de los hechos
cotidianos
lo contrario a estos grandes hitos que
de pronto definen la vida de un país o
del mundo
y por eso les voy a platicar un poquito
de quién soy y de dónde vengo mis
abuelos llegaron a vivir aquí en los
cincuentas finales principios de los
sesenta cuando acapulco era un lugar
todavía muy virgen había poca gente y se
empezó a llenar de una gran
población que venían de profesionistas y
de mexicanos o extranjeros que venían a
invertir y pues iniciaron con una vida
turística que después se fue
consolidando en los siguientes años
en la década en 1964 mi abuelo hizo
notario público número 7 en los setentas
mis papás se conocieron se casaron aquí
y también así otro dato importante de
esa década es que fue cuando hubo una
explosión demográfica y acapulco no
estaba preparado para recibirla
pues
todo fue muy tranquilo en los 80s salvo
por el tema
que para mí era muy difícil escuela a mí
me costaba mucho trabajo ir a clases
me aterraba hacer tareas me aterrado que
me pasaron al pizarrón y
siempre a pesar de que me esforzaba
mucho y estaba en el cuadro de honor yo
sentía que no era suficiente sentía que
me faltaba un poquito sentía que había
algo que se había quedado pendiente que
la calificación no era la correcta que
podía haberlo hecho mejor y ese nivel de
creer en estas cosas en creer que era
muy importante el reconocimiento
académico me empezó a generar un
problema de autoestima
después de allí
pues como sea termine la prepa en el
camino durante durante la secundaria
empezó a ver problemas en casa la verdad
es que la vida nocturna de acapulco que
no sé si ustedes se acuerden no les han
contado pero era todos los días era una
fuente de tentación permanente y la
infidelidad pues empezó a causar
estragos
ahora lo vemos como algo muy normal en
las telenovelas se habla de son las
canciones de reggaetón y la gente piensa
que es algo divertido incluso a veces
pero realmente el romper una promesa en
una pareja genera estragos en la
relación
causa un problema de
oslo - es una excepción hay coraje y
sentimientos que se van generando y eso
afecta también a los hijos
en mi caso pues eso produjo una
estabilidad familiar y cuando yo iba en
prepa en 1994 fue que se tuvimos la
crisis del 94 no sé si ustedes usan
muchos de ustedes no les tocó pero fue
una gran crisis que puso en riesgo a
muchos de los empresarios acapulqueños
porque las los períodos de abundancia y
de bonanza habían sido tan nobles que la
mayoría no estaban preparados para una
crisis y lo que pasó fue que con la
devaluación muchos de los empresarios
que tenían créditos cotizados en dólares
se les volvieron impagables hubo en este
momento una gran reestructuración del
sistema financiero
empezaron a hablar de los sietes y se
empezaron a hacer reestructuraciones y
en ese periodo el negocio familiar no
salió bien librado a pesar de eso con
todos los temas familiares y le sumó lo
económico al igual que la mayoría de mis
amigos me dio a vivir fuera de acapulco
no hacía estudiar la universidad al itam
a méxico
pues me hacía vivir sola
la
vida universitaria no fue más fácil
estar en un entorno altamente
competitivo fuera de casa en un ambiente
que era totalmente ajeno me causó más
problemas de autoestima
yo no tenía los medios para
desenvolverme como yo quería como
socialmente yo pensaba
e
pues empecé a tratar de controlar lo
único que podía controlar que era mi
cuerpo y dejé de comer y empecé con un
periodo de anorexia en el que hacía
media comida al día no tenía nutrientes
no podía pensar y todo este ciclo me
reafirmaba esta creencia negativa de que
no podía de que no era lo
suficientemente inteligente o lo
suficientemente capaz
más o menos empecé a salir de esas
cuando empecé a evadir me en las fiestas
yo sé que sobre todo en la universidad
es muy fácil tienes pocas
responsabilidades y se divierte uno pero
todo tiene un punto de equilibrio y
cuando ese punto de equilibrio lo empecé
a traspasar en realidad no me hacía
sentir bien
yo siempre había querido hacer las cosas
bien había querido ser una persona muy
correcta
y
había generaba como un pequeño vacío que
solamente se llenaba después de que
tomaba otra actitud similar entonces
un día
hice crisis y pues tenía miedo yo creo
que a ustedes les pasa tenía miedo
cuando estaba saliendo de la escuela
tenía miedo de no ser suficientemente
inteligente suficientemente capaz de no
ganar lo suficiente de que el día de
mañana tal vez no iba a conocer una
persona que me valorará lo suficiente
como para formar una familia
en estos procesos el negocio familiar
terminó de cerrar mi familia se terminó
de disolver yo hice crisis
e intenté suicidarme
y eso pues afortunadamente no pude no
tuve las fuerzas pared y termina
llorando pero este fondo fue un inicio
yo me di cuenta que si iba a estar sobre
esta tierra tenía que hacer que cada día
valieron 100 por ciento la pena y a
partir de ahí empecé a preguntarme cómo
si podía lograr una vida feliz y como si
podía construir un escenario que me
gustara y entonces recordé esta frase
que había estado conmigo en mi cabeza
todos esos años pero que no la
practicaba y es la forma en que vivimos
nuestros días es la forma en que vivimos
nuestra vida y esta frase se convirtió
como un mantra y me empezar cuenta que
tenía que vivir mis días de una manera
más plena más feliz más comprometida y
empecé
puedes explorar pregunta preguntar a ver
cómo se hacía
como no sabía qué hacer lo que sí supe
fue parar dejar de hacer lo que me hacía
sentir mal
eso incluyó alejarme algunas amistades
romper hábitos y empezar a preguntar
nuevos sitios
y empezar a construir lo que sí quería
para mí
y parte de eso fue venirme a vivir
acapulco que ha sido un proceso largo es
un proceso permanente me costó trabajo
salir de la ciudad de méxico- para
venirme aquí pues porque yo tenía mis
amigos tenía mucha gente que quería
había cosas que me gustaban hacer
sobre todo mi mejor amiga y su familia
se han vuelto una segunda familia para
mí pero me vine
empecé a trabajar con mi abuelito
se convirtió a mi nueva figura paterna
mi mamá fue una ancla y empecé un
proceso largo de sanación
algo que fue muy importante fue que en
ese último estirón de la universidad una
maestra me canalizó a un centro de
especial para aprendizaje y resultó que
todos esos años de estar tocando piedra
y que sentía que no encajaba tener una
gran explicación
soy una persona altamente disléxico
hiperactiva y con déficit de atención o
sea que estaba en chino y la escuela
pero lo que aprendí también es que las
personas que tienen dislexia dislalia
desgracia hiperactividad o déficit de
atención en realidad son igual de
inteligentes o más que el promedio medio
esto quiere decir que no es un problema
de no puedo o no tengo sino simplemente
a veces no están las herramientas o las
formas adecuadas para explotar esas
capacidades
yo soy disléxico y eso significa que
tengo un cerebro muy visual puedo
recordar muy bien mapas cuadros
diagramas espacios y hay cosas que se me
complican un poquito más entonces lo que
pude aprender en esta experiencia fue a
trabajar mis fortalezas también me tocó
ir a terapia con la psicóloga
y ahí aprendí que cuando las chavas
tenemos vivimos en una relación de abuso
de alguna manera es muy poco fácil que
salgamos de ese patrón es muy difícil
que las mujeres víctimas de una
situación de violencia la rompan cuando
empiezan jóvenes es más difícil que
continúen con estudios universitarios y
con esto en la universidad del
porcentaje que se gradúa es mínimo
y yo
después de todo eso me di cuenta que era
como el salmón que nadaba
contracorriente me di cuenta que eran la
minoría de la minoría de la minoría y
eso me hizo darme cuenta que si eran
suficientes que era suficientemente
capaz suficientemente perseverante
suficientemente fuerte suficientemente
tenaz incluso está inteligente
y entonces empecé a aceptarme y empecé a
buscar formas de quererme y
pues a raíz de aceptar que soy
suficiente empecé a hacer más
cómo decirlo como
a tratar de construir por dentro y algo
que hace una herramienta vital fue
y ser congruentes entre lo que pienso
/ lo que siento lo que pienso y lo que
digo ser congruente me ha dado así una
gran herramienta que me ha dado paz
mental me ha dado mayor respeto a mí
misma me ha dado estabilidad y todo eso
se refleja en un mayor amor a mí misma
en algún momento del camino llegó otra
frase a mi vida que se quedó para
siempre yo soy yo y mis circunstancias
si no salvo mis circunstancias no me
salvo yo que quiere decir que yo soy la
que soy en el entorno en que me muevo yo
soy la que soy en este momento de mi
vida y si quiero cambiar si quiero
crecer si quiero que algo sea diferente
tengo que también cambiar mis
circunstancias no solamente un trabajo
personal es un trabajo de reacomodar las
circunstancias y las cosas que nos tocan
vivir para poder generar nuevos
escenarios
me di cuenta también de que la pregunta
no es porque sino para que qué voy a
hacer con eso que me pasó y cómo lo voy
a aprovechar me di cuenta que todo
estaba en mi actitud las cosas podrían
ser un problema un reto una tristeza o
podían ser una oportunidad de crecer de
aprender y una herramienta después para
superar otras cosas que se presentaran y
empecé a construir círculos virtuosos
después de detenerme y dejar de hacer lo
que me lastimaba empecé a concentrarme
en lo que sí quería y empecé a generar
dinámicas que me ayudaron a cambiar poco
a poco mi vida y a rodearme de cosas
positivas en el 2010 me tocó vivir una
prueba de fuego mi abuelo que había sido
ya como mi papá falleció y fue de verdad
un gran reto no salirme de lyon
creer que todo pasaba por alguna razón
preguntarme para qué
recordar que en todo momento
el dolor es inevitable pero el
sufrimiento es opcional como dicen los
budistas y también
que siempre se puede dar lo mejor en
cualquier circunstancia
con el tiempo sane la relación con mi
papá lo busqué nos encontramos la verdad
es que soy muy feliz de que esté en mi
vida lo quiero muchísimo
es parte de crecer y finalmente después
de muchos años conocía el amor de mi
vida que me ayuda y me impulsa a ser una
mejor versión de mí misma y hace unos
meses nació nuestro bebé que sin duda él
es el mayor privilegio que tengo
pues 2011 fui otra como un punto de
quiebre en mi vida porque fue cuando
después de hacer el examen me volví
notario público número 7 y les quiero
contar que algo que me encanta de lo que
hago es que los notarios damos fe la fe
se presume como algo cierto que no se
puede ver ni comprobar pero que se cree
que es y más allá del tema legal estoy
convencida de que las personas
necesitamos fe para salir adelante de
nuestros problemas fe para creer en el
escenario que podemos construir y
dedicarnos a eso y necesitamos también
confianza confianza en nosotros mismos
confianza en que la vida no nos va a dar
nada que no podamos manejarlo
regresando al tema de la microhistoria
parte de todo este vehículo aunque me
hicieron favor de leerles y de que
participe en todas estas otras
actividades es porque estoy convencida
que además hay que poner un granito de
arena en mejorar las circunstancias
colectivas tenemos que empezar a
replantearnos la historia colectiva que
nos contamos tenemos que dejar de ser
víctimas de las circunstancias tenemos
que empezar a construir el escenario que
si queremos para nuestros hijos y sus
nietos tenemos en sí que mejorar
nuestras circunstancias y me gusta la
microhistoria porque cada uno de ustedes
tienen la oportunidad de cada día
levantarse y elegir un sueño todos
ustedes están vivos por algo todos
tienen la oportunidad de construir sus
circunstancias de mejorar su mundo y de
crear círculos virtuosos en los que
quepamos todos muchas gracias
[Música]